[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
he just
said i shot somebody i shot somebody and
then hung up right away a friend of
accused shooter kyle rittenhouse speaks
about the moments that followed the
deadly kenosha protest and a jury is
seated in georgia for the trial of the
death of a mod arbory brian buckmeyer is
live on the ground with more plus a
shocking claim hear from attorneys for
the armorer on the set of rust about
what could have led to the fatal
shooting and later the defendant is
guilty of first-degree murder of a law
enforcement officer a verdict is in for
markeith loyd's second murder trial we
discuss more on the next steps for this
convicted cop killer law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome to law and crime daily i am your
host imran ansari filling in for brian
buckmeyer while he is on assignment in
georgia covering the trial for the death
of ahmad arbury co-host terry austin
also joins me today
we enter into day two of testimony in
wisconsin for the accused kenosha's
shooter kyle rittenhouse 18 year old
ridden house faces multiple charges
including first-degree reckless homicide
intentional homicide and attempted
homicide the charges stem from the 2020
kenosha riots following the shooting of
jacob blake a black man shot by a white
police officer
prosecutors say that the teenager shot
three people during the protests joseph
rosenbaum and anthony huber were killed
gage gross kroitz was wounded
rittenhouse says he acted in
self-defense
the prosecution's first witness was
dominic black a friend of the defendant
who accompanied him the evening of the
riots black is also the person who
purchased the gun for ridden house prior
to the incident he also faces criminal
charges on direct examination black
described written house in the moments
following the shooting
he just
said i shot somebody i shot somebody and
then hung up right away
he was freaking out he was really scared
he was pale sweating a lot
um
you could tell he was just scared
did he say anything
he wasn't really talking he just said he
had to do it it was self-defense he used
people are trying to hurt him
did he ever say to you
that
someone was trying to attack him with a
gun no did he ever say to you that
someone was trying to attack him with a
knife no did they ever say to you that
anyone was trying to attack him with any
sort of weapon
no
on cross the defense attorney questioned
black about his decision to take guns to
the protest in the first place
you wanted a gun personally for myself
yes you had no objection or voice no
objection
to kyle your brother having the gun
correct
it wasn't a thought in my mind well he
walks out of the house with an ar-15 and
you don't say boo correct
i didn't say anything correct and
you have the ability to speak
yes
if you wanted to object
you could have said something to kyle
correct yes i could have and you did
because you wanted him to have the gun
for protection
not that reason exactly
you wanted a gun for protection
yes
let's bring back our co-host terry
austin and our guest today legal analyst
dina dahl to break this down
dina this witness had a lot to say about
the night of the shooting and what led
up to it do you think that he was more
helpful to the prosecution or to the
defense with his testimony
he was not all that useful to either
except for the fact that he laid out the
fact
to the jury that one he was illegally
had this gun he was underage and you
know there's a reason why we have laws
for underage because we don't believe
they have the judgment
which leads into this here did he have
the correct judgment in shooting those
people and it also kind of goes to the
fact that there was a group of them that
went into the city with the purpose of
quote defending these businesses so the
prosecution needed that to lay out the
story but the defense was also able to
get some things in that were helpful to
them such as the fact that he himself
also believed he needed to have a gun
but i think the prosecution did a great
job of also saying nobody else killed
anybody that night except for the
defendant yeah now terry let me ask you
dominic black was the first witness
called to the stand why do you think the
prosecution chose him first
well i think he was chosen first because
he was the one person who could
establish that timeline of the events
that dina was just talking about he was
with the defendant before during and
after the event and he frankly in my
humble opinion at his young age is
fairly well spoken he came across as
very calm he came across as very
credible and he is the best friend of
kyle rittenhouse he dated kyle's sister
and yet he testified against kyle so i
think that gave him a lot of credibility
as far as the jury is concerned and the
other thing i'll say is he was fair and
he was
as far as both the prosecution and the
defense was concerned he was deferential
to both of them so i think that was good
yeah we're going to wait and see what
happens in this trial but still ahead
here on law on crime daily who is to
blame for the deadly shooting on the
rust movie set hear from the attorneys
of hannah gutierrez reid the movie's
armor
but first jury selection is nearing an
end in georgia our own brian buckmeyer
is live with more on the trial for the
death of ahmad arber
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charge will now stand
trial for live galil gabo coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
[Music]
welcome back to law on crime daily and
after more than three weeks the magic
number has finally been reached for
jurors in georgia in the trial for the
death of ahmad arbury attorneys will
select a jury and alternates from a
final pool of 65 they will decide the
fate of gregory and travis mcmichael and
william roddy bryan who all face charges
of malice murder felony murder and
aggravated assault for the shooting of
25 year old jogger ahmad arbury
prosecutors say that the father and son
gregory and travis mcmichael followed
aubry in their pickup truck as he ran
near his home in georgia back in
february of 2020. travis mcmichael shot
and killed arberry claiming self-defense
brian followed along in his own vehicle
recording this on his phone opening
statements are set for thursday morning
joining us now is our very own brian
buckmeyer who is live on the ground in
georgia outside the courthouse brian
what are your main takeaways from court
today in georgia
imran it started fast and furious from
this morning where we had 65 potential
jurors come in and then just a few
moments later they were walked out of
the court because kevin goff the
attorney for william bryant brought up
multiple issues some of the more notable
ones is that he said that one of the
jurors found he found out there was a
tick tock account and questioned him
about that now he questioned that person
to the point uh that almost seemed like
a cross-examination and as they walked
off that jordan shook their head and was
disqualified because the judge said they
couldn't be impartial to the defendant
now i also brought up the bubba argument
that ended up just ending off with them
saying i simply want the questionnaires
to be saved but this afternoon it all
things hit the roof where 12
african-american juries made it to the
first round but 11 of them were struck
by the defense and arguments about a
batson challenge that that the defense
was eliminating based on race grow in a
large volume in this case now arguments
by goff appear to slow down proceedings
something that the attorney for wanda
cooper jones lee merritt commented on
goth is uh doing a bit of grandstanding
he's enjoying the limelight a little too
much this is serious this is a murder
trial
his client participated in the murder of
my client's son
so a bubble motion or whatever he wants
to call it is neither uh a legal remedy
it's not entertaining it's not something
that we want to continue to discuss we
want to get to the truck
now brian i was waiting for a batson
challenge during this jury selection and
here it is can you explain to our
viewers what is a bastion challenge
so imran there are different types of
challenges you can have what's called a
four cause challenge a person can't
follow the rules of the court for
example or has an implicit bias in the
case there's also what's called
peremptory challenges where the defense
or prosecution can simply eliminate a
person just because they don't think the
right person but if you use that
peremptory challenge and the other side
believes
eliminating people based on race gender
or any kind of protected class you can
make a challenge to that peremptory
challenge and say that you're
eliminating people not because they
can't follow the law or the rules of the
court but based on this occasion on race
and what were some of the arguments that
both the defense and the prosecution
made
so it's interesting for the defense
they're treating this as a second bite
of the apple trying to eliminate those
african-american jurors who said things
that they didn't like but the judge
still kept them on because the end of
the day they said that even if they have
some sort of bias as many of the
potentially said that they can put those
aside and listen to the rules of the
court and the judge's instructions the
prosecution on the other side is saying
that both white black brown and every
race under the color said the exact same
thing that they have certain pre uh
conceived notions about the case but can
put those aside but only the
african-american jurors were eliminated
while the white jurors will not brian
thank you for your great reporting
coming up on law on crime daily a
florida jury comes to a speedy verdict
in markeith loyd's second murder trial
what was their decision coming up
shortly plus the attorneys for the rust
movie armor hannah gutierrez reid speaks
out about what they think happened the
day of the fatal incident
[Music]
attorneys for the armor on the set of
rust are defending their client in a new
interview and suggests someone may have
wanted to sabotage the set by bringing
in live ammunition lawn crimes anjanet
levy is here with more on what lawyers
are saying angeannette
imran hannah gutierrez reid is that 24
year old armorer who was in charge of
the firearms on the set and get this her
lawyers actually suggested that some of
the crew members may have been unhappy
with the working conditions and that's
possibly how that live ammo made it onto
the set
the person who put the live round in the
box of dummy rounds had to have the
purpose of sabotaging this set that
suggestion was made by attorneys for
hannah gutierrez reid speaking to the
today show on nbc wednesday morning
gutierrez reid loaded the gun used by
alec baldwin according to her lawyers
but they say it was left unattended for
two hours that day
jason bulls says gutierrez reid loaded
the gun with cartridges that came from a
box of dummies
she loaded rounds from that box into the
the handgun
uh only later to find out there is a and
she had no idea she inspected the rounds
that there was a live round now we don't
know however
whether that live round came from that
box we're assuming it did
the facts are in dispute the lawyers
claim gutierrez reid gave the gun to
assistant director dave halls and showed
him the drum to inspect halls's lawyer
has suggested he didn't have the weapon
but a search warrant affidavit quotes
halls is saying he should have checked
the revolver before handing it to
baldwin alec baldwin fired the gun last
month as he practiced a cross-draw
killing cinematographer helena hutchins
and wounding director joel souza
bobby chacon is a technical advisor on
tv shows and explains how firearms
should be handled on sets in my opinion
and it's good practice i believe to have
the armor or deal directly with the cast
member um no middleman
and alec baldwin is actually disputing
all of these claims that the working
conditions on the set were so poor that
people were walking away and upset about
it he reposted on instagram one of the
crew members facebook posts and therese
davis used a curse word
that begins with bull to actually
describe these complaints about the
working conditions she also went on to
say that there were accidental
discharges on the set and she said the
guns were checked immediately and that
those discharges are more common than
you would think imran
okay so let's break this down everyone
dina i'm going to start with you with
the suggestion of sabotage here is it
possible that some criminal charges may
be coming down the line and how viable
do you think that these charges would be
it definitely raises there could be
criminal charges even if there is not
this sabotage because there could be of
some recklessness on their part but the
implication that this was intentional
that's what the sabotage claim is that
somebody intentionally put a real bullet
among the bullets could then raise the
criminal charge to some sort of
intentional homicide i mean we are very
much in the beginning of this
investigation
it's you know common for an attorney
he's really coming out to try to defend
the reputation
of his client who's had a lot of press
reports kind of putting the blame on her
and he's coming out to defend her here
but we still have to see the facts
yeah terry how might this new
information about sabotage shift the
focus of the investigation as it's
currently underway
well it certainly will take it up a
notch it's going to shift from that
criminal or civil liability dealing with
negligence to criminal liability dealing
with intent and some sort of motive as
angenette said in her package
the
implication here is that someone wanted
to sabotage the whole set and if that's
the case they're going to have to look
for people who might have these grudges
and essentially everyone will be under
suspicion
yeah anjanette these are somewhat bold
uh you know a suggestion to say that
this was sabotage it's a bold thing to
come out uh and come forward and say
that
did hannah gutierrez reid's lawyers
offer anything to back up their claims
of that sabotage
yeah it is a rather bold claim i would
agree with you on that imran and no they
didn't they said you know they don't
even really have a working theory here
they're still working on gathering facts
and they discussed how you know the fbi
and the santa fe county sheriff's office
detectives would be investigating this
and trying to determine how that live
ammo made it on set obviously as the
armorer on the set gutierrez reed would
be responsible for looking over those
cartridges because they are different um
from actual product projectiles when
loading that gun
yeah i think we're all going to be
watching how this investigation unfolds
thank you when we come back the verdict
is in for markeith loyd in his second
murder trial we'll take you inside that
florida courtroom for closing arguments
and explain what the next steps are for
the convicted cop killer
[Music]
as to count one of the charge
the defendant is guilty of first-degree
murder of a law enforcement officer
well welcome back and the verdict is in
for mark keith lloyd as you just saw
there george deliberated for
approximately five hours before finding
him guilty on all counts in the murder
of lieutenant debra clayton lloyd shot
clayton in 2017 as she tried to arrest
him for the murder of his pregnant
ex-girlfriend chaudet dixon lloyd is
serving a life sentence for that murder
lloyd faces the possibility of the death
penalty in clayton's murder he spent
more than three hours on the stand
testifying that he feared for his life
and acted in self-defense
in closing arguments the state suggested
that lloyd always had a motivation to
kill pointing out evidence from a
facebook post the penalty phase begins
saturday
i rather die than live my life
it is not a secret there's been evidence
that mr lloyd was in prison
up until 2014
and he's made it clear through his
facebook post he was not going back
lieutenant clayton's
goal
her only goal on the morning of january
9th was to bring him into custody and
that was one of the few things he would
simply not allow
the defendant had a motivation to kill
and in the defense's closing arguments
attorney terence lenimon maintained that
the argument that his client was in fear
for his life and had no choice but to
shoot clayton
and he's going to defend himself
then the minute that he turns around
with a gun
he's not going to stop firing until
she doesn't have a gun
where he's not in danger anymore
once the first
shot is fired and now he's reacting
and she still has her in her hand and
she's
in a matter of seconds
what does the state want to happen
for him to stop and run away while she
has a gun pointed at him
they're still firing at each other
he could not stop in his tracks he could
not walk away
and after closings concluded and outside
the presence of the jury the defendant
went off in the courtroom about why he
thinks his trial was unfair
is there anything else that you asked
your attorneys to say
it's a bunch of stuff
it's a bunch of stuff do you want to
list it now
no because i'm cause i'm upset right now
and i'm about to can't even talk anymore
all right because they don't
think
watch your language
take a deep breath and calm down
they slow
they think they're so smart but they're
not more intelligent than me
is there any other than the muslim mr
lloyd focus
mr lloyd you need to look at me and
focus
okay let's break this down dina i'm
going to start with you the jury
deliberated for close to five hours over
the course of two days were you
surprised with this rather speedy
verdict than the outcome
no the defense did the best job they
could but the evidence was overwhelming
there was the video footage the fact
that he was
a fugitive having been convicted of
murder
she was doing her job and he killed her
so i i'm not surprised i think that some
of the mental health issues that were
brought up may go into mitigating
whether or not he receives
you know concurrent life in prison or
the death penalty it might help him
avoid the death penalty but certainly
not enough to help him avoid a
conviction yeah certainly swift justice
now terry
the death penalty the only issue which
remains is whether lloyd is going to get
the death penalty what are your thoughts
on that
well i think if any case gets the death
penalty it will be this case we are in
the state of florida and the aggravating
factors there are numerous that apply to
this case he shot and killed a law
enforcement officer he's a prior felon
he was trying to avoid custody this was
a heinous crime it was great risk to
others because there were others in that
parking lot at walmart so i do believe
that he might get the death penalty here
the only thing and dina mentioned this
that could save him is the fact he may
have that mental illness and remember
imran the state of florida does have a
history of putting people to death
they're currently 305 prisoners on
prison row and they've executed 99 since
1976. yeah we will be watching that
sentencing phase indeed so thank you
everyone for joining us here on the law
on crime daily and we're going to be
seeing you next time to discuss justice
in america and court cases across the
country
[Music]
you